bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
c'est l'image du jour la poignée de main
entre sea Jinping et Joe Biden premier
face à face entre les deux hommes trois
heures d'entretien en marge du sommet du
G20 à Bali une rencontre alors que les
tensions entre les deux pays sont au
plus haut la Chine déploie des exercices
militaires depuis la visite de Nancy
Pelosi à Taïwan les États-Unis viennent
de mettre en place des mesures de
contrôle à l'exportation pour empêcher
Pékin de développer les puces
nécessaires à l'armée à l'intelligence
artificielle ou encore à l'informatique
quantique mais à l'issue de cette
entrevue Joe Biden et sea jinpim se
serait mis d'accord sur leur opposition
à tout recours à l'arme nucléaire en
Ukraine en tout cas c'est ce que dit la
Maison Blanche même si Pékin refuse
toujours de condamner l'invasion russe
alors ce face à face hidding Joe Biden
peut-il désamorcer les tensions entre
les deux pays l'absence de Vladimir
Poutine au G20 a-t-elle favorisé
entretien les États-Unis et la Chine en
désaccord sur l'Ukraine Taïwan ou encore
les droits de l'homme sont-ils en mesure
d'avoir un dialogue constructif on en
débat avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir mes côtés Marie-Françoise bechel
bonsoir vous êtes président de la
Fondation reste publique bienvenue à
vous en face de vous à nickel bonsoir
enseignante chercheuse anniversaire
bonne nouvelle spécialiste de la
politique étrangère américaine avec nous
également Jean-François d'imeglio
bonsoir président DGA Center professeur
Université Paris Dauphine et à la Public
School of internationals vous êtes
également économiste bienvenue à vous en
face de vous pierres Antoine donnait
bonsoir journaliste auteur de Chine le
grand prédateur un défi pour la planète
c'est aux Éditions de l'Aube vous avez
également dirigé donc l'ouvrage qui sort
en octobre aux éditions cherche midi le
dossier chinois portrait d'un pays au
bord de la Bible bienvenue merci
Joe Biden et sidjin ping ont donc passé
trois heures ensemble pour la première
fois depuis que Biden est président le
président américain et le chef de l'État
chinois ce sont dit après donc à un
dialogue malgré leur rivalité Cécile
l'exercice était attendu pas de
déclaration commune Jo Biden apparait
seul devant les caméras après 3 heures
d'entretien avec son homologue chinois
je viens de rencontrer en personne le
président sid-jin ping de la République
populaire de Chine nous avons une
conversation ouverte et franche sur nos
intentions et nos priorités
impossible pour les deux hommes de
gommer leur divergence mais au moins ils
ont aux yeux de tous afficher leur
intention commune réduire au maximum les
contentieux le premier et non des
moindres Taïwan
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait d'intention
imminente de la part de la Chine
d'envahir Taïwan et j'ai été clair que
notre politique concernant Taïwan n'a
pas changé du tout
le principe d'une seule Chine prenait
par Pékin n'est pas du goût de
Washington les tensions ont grimpé d'un
cran en août dernier lorsque Nancy
pelodi la présidente de la Chambre des
Représentants était en visite sur l'île
depuis Pékin ne décolère toujours pas la
question de Taïwan est au coeur même des
intérêts fondamentaux de la Chine le
fondement politique des relations
sino-américaines et la première ligne
rouge à ne pas franchir la résolution de
la question de Taïwan elle l'a fait des
Chinois
les velléités nucléaires de la Corée du
Nord ont également été abordés il
s'agissait pour Joe Biden de pousser et
sea Jin ping à jouer de son influence
pour modérer et puis en Yang
je suis convaincu que la Chine ne
cherche pas à ce que la Corée du Nord
s'engage dans une nouvelle escalade et
j'ai été clair avec le Président si
jimping si la Corée du Nord entreprenait
des essais nucléaires de longue portée
nous serions obligés de prendre des
mesures plus défensives de notre côté
ce à quoi le ministère chinois des
Affaires étrangères répond que Pékin ne
cherche en aucun cas à défier les
États-Unis
cette rencontre c'était leur premier
face à face en tant que président et
l'on retiendra cette image une poignée
de mains en franche entre les deux
dirigeants les plus puissants de la
planète
Jean-François d'immiglio c'est un peu
difficile de décrypter exactement ce
qu'elle puisse passer pendant ces 3
heures entre byden et ce qu'on se dirige
vers une des escalade on va dire que on
se ménage effectivement une zone de
respiration
sans reprendre textuellement le titre de
de l'ouvrage de Antoine denè je dirais
qu'effectivement
la Chine de Sitting s'est ency malgré
l'apparente réussite éclatante du XXème
congrès est au pied du mur la récession
en Chine ça n'existe pas mais quand on
est à deux et demi de croissance quand
tu as 3 % de croissance quand on a une
démographie qui menace quand on a un
taux de d'emploi qui est aussi mauvais
en ce moment qu'il est et bien on ne
peut plus trop se préoccuper d'un
affrontement direct et frontal avec le
partenaire de toujours une pause et
c'est le besoin d'une pause
exactement
c'est la mi-temps vous êtes d'accord
anxisal vous qui êtes la spécialiste
machine logiquement presque c'est
presque le terme qu'ils utilisent alors
je vous plaisante parfois avec mes
étudiants en disant qu'entre le mot
anglais country et countain entre
contraindre et contenir il y a deux
lettres d'écart en anglais le S et le r
je crois mais avec ce dialogue je vous
en sort un petit peu cette logique en
même temps il y a eu une énorme pression
de la part des pays du Sud et quand Tony
blinken est allé en Afrique d'ailleurs
tous les pays africains où il est allé à
commencer par le Kenya lui ont dit nous
nous ne voulons pas de cette guerre
froide l'Union européenne ne veut pas de
cette guerre froide donc Washington est
sans doute en train de s'adapter aussi
un temps de pause une mi-temps de
reculer un petit peu sur cette logique
d'affrontement de blocs qu'on voyait
arriver et puis aussi parce qu'il faut
ménager la Chine face à la Russie
Marie-France vous êtes d'accord on est
dans une logique de pose alors que les
tensions sont extrêmement fortes les
intéressés par cette idée selon laquelle
qui vient d'être développée selon
laquelle les États-Unis n'ont plus un
bloc derrière eux nous avons eu de la
guerre froide il y avait des blocs on
appelait ça les blocs justement et puis
il y avait des lignes ligne rouge celle
dont a parlé Biden plus récemment qu'il
fallait pas franchir sur Taïwan par
exemple aujourd'hui sur Taïwan à
l'époque c'était d'autres lignes et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve plutôt dans
une guerre congelée si j'ose dire au
lieu d'une guerre froide c'est à dire
chacun sait ce qu'il a reproché à
l'autre mais sans doute personne ne fera
pas avant j'étais frappé je crois que
c'est dans le communiqué du de la Maison
Blanche par l'idée par la déclaration de
Biden c'est pas dans le communiqué sa
déclaration après le sommet disant qu'il
n'y aura pas d'attaque imminente de
Taïwan c'est dire qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire les États-Unis prennent prennent
leur précaution et sans finalement et
marche
très délicatement sur une zone fissu
durable Pierre Antoine donnez vous êtes
d'accord c'est moi qui a priori ils
s'entendent sur rien enfin sur les
droits de l'homme on en parle pas sur
l'Ukraine parce que la Chine elle n'a
toujours pas dit qu'elle était qu'elle
n'était pas un soutien de la Russie un
seul ne l'a pas dit sur Taïwan on sait
également on est dans ce combat entre
les démocraties et les régimes
autoritaires donc c'est vrai qu'on se
demande est-ce qu'on est dans un
dialogue de sourd là cette pause
qu'est-ce que c'est
oui je pense qu'effectivement c'est une
pause et nul ne peut vraiment prédire ce
qui se passera dans six mois un an mais
ceci dit
cette entretien donc il y a duré plus de
trois heures intervient à un moment où
les cartes géopolitiques ont été
entièrement redistribués et ça a bien
sûr été accéléré le 24 février lorsque
la Russie Vladimir Poutine a décidé
d'envahir l'Ukraine
et quelques jours avant
la nuit Poutine se trouvait à Pékin pour
rencontrer ses inping juste avant le
début des Jeux Olympiques et il se
trouve aujourd'hui que la Chine déclète
très clairement par l'intermédiaire de
responsable non identifié qui s'en sont
ouverts au final qui a aucun moment
Vladimir Poutine n'avait dit à Sidiki ce
qui comptait faire donc aujourd'hui
clairement la Chine dit nous avons été
très embarrassés par tout ce qui s'est
passé alors un allié fort de la Russie
mais elle ne dit pas qu'elle n'est pas
son allié mais vous savez quand dans ce
bras de fer entre la Chine et les
États-Unis la Chine compte ses alliés et
parmi ces alliés il y a bien sur la
Corée du Nord qui ne compte pas quand
même beaucoup sur les cycles
international et puis la Russie d'une
manière ou d'une autre même si c'est un
nain sur le plan économique sur le plan
militaire c'est autre chose
Jean-François dit miglio justement elle
ne condamne pas la Russie toujours pas
la Chine elle aurait pu le faire là
en plus en l'absence de Vladimir Poutine
à part
des éléments très choquants dans
l'idéologie chinoise il est très rare
que la voie chinoise condamne on a un
ambassadeur chinois
en France qui condamne qui a souvent une
parole extrêmement violente mais sur la
scène internationale en général la Chine
est extrêmement prudente alors
sécurité pour débloquer et elle elle
n'en voit pas de message clair pour
toutes sortes de raisons d'abord parce
que si vous me permettez moi je
reprendrai le terme d'allier elle n'a
pas d'allier le concept d'alliance en
fait la Corée du Nord et son allié par
exemple oui mais ça c'est la même façon
que baiden a dit il n'est pas dans
l'intérêt de la Chine mais comment
peut-on dire quand on est président
américain ce qui est l'intérêt de la
Chine ou pas on peut pas mais en
revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que la
Chine ne joue pas avec les mêmes cartes
d'alliance clivée que nous et donc
effectivement la situation de la Russie
on ne peut pas dire que la Chine soit
une adversaire de la Russie on ne peut
pas dire que j'ai choisi un camp
différent de celui de la Russie mais on
ne peut pas dire pour autant qu'elle ait
choisi le camp de la Russie et là on
sort d'un sommet donc du Shanghai
organiser ou pour le coup Poutine était
là
je l'ai rappelé ici même si bien pris
soin non pas d'aller directement à sa
marquant mais bien de s'arrêter au
Kazakhstan qui était un territoire qui
comptait beaucoup autrefois pour la
Russie pour bien dire que ça marquant
était au moins aussi important que le
Kazakhstan anxial mais tout de même Joe
Biden rappelle toujours cette politique
des droits de l'homme c'est vraiment les
démocraties contre l'autocratie contre
les autocraties contre les dictatures
là-dessus la Chine dans la tête des
Américains c'est tout de même la lié de
la Russie d'un point de vue idéologique
alors c'est un partenaire privilégié au
sein de l'Organisation de coopération de
Shanghai car dans à l'esprit je crois
aussi que la Chine est extrêmement
dépendante pour ces hydrocarbures de la
Russie bien évidemment il ne va pas
répudier son premier fournisseur
certaines ne se désalignera pas de la
Russie mais la Chine est-elle alignée
sur la Russie est-ce qu'elle joue ses
cartes ou est-ce que finalement ce qui
rapproche c'est de puissance la Russie
et la Chine ça n'est pas l'antioxydant
ça n'est pas construire alors pas
forcément un ordre mondial différent de
celui d'aujourd'hui dans le sens où la
Chine et omniprésente à l'ONU et se sert
de l'ONU à la fois de l'assemblée
générale et de ses amis de ses cercles
d'amis au sein de l'assemblée générale
et de sa position prédominante dans un
certain nombre d'agences de l'ONU mais
en même temps le système les valeurs qui
seraient mises en avant par une Chine
dominatrice prépondérante ne seront pas
les mêmes que celles des États-Unis ça
commence par la démocratie et évidemment
ça inclut les droits humains 5 rue aussi
le sommet de la cop27 en Égypte la
position chinoise est moins coopératrice
que celle moins coopérative que celle du
monde occidental Joe Biden attendait ou
plus exactement son émissaire John Kerry
pour le climat a tenté de tendre la main
vers les Chinois pour remettre en
opération pour rendre opérationnel à
nouveau les groupes de travail entre la
Chine et les États-Unis qui petit signe
de détente avait fonctionné sous Obama
au moment de la cop21 et ça a été une
fin de non-recevoir complète
Marie-Françoise béchez qu'effectivement
la politique des droits de l'homme de
Joe Biden peut s'accommoder d'un
dialogue avec la Chine oui alors d'abord
je crois qu'elle est un peu la géométrie
variable la politique droit de l'homme
n'a pas toujours été comment dirais-je
le faire de l'anse de la politique
américaine on se souvient de l'époque
brisinsky ou brevinsky théoriser le
régime change il a changé d'avis à la
fin de sa vie d'ailleurs en pensant que
il ne fallait pas que les États-Unis à
la limite
comment dirais-je soutiennent des coups
d'état ou du moins changement de régime
ce qui est complètement contraire à ce
que fut l'histoire diplomatique dans le
monde Westfalia c'est-à-dire on
reconnaît les éteindre touche pas au
régime donc là dessus on est quand même
sur une ligne de Crète je crois que les
droits de l'homme en bandeau si je puis
dire mais Biden a l'air c'est
aujourd'hui oui alors c'est toujours lui
le cheval sur lequel on monte hier
c'était un autre et demain ça sera
peut-être un autre je voudrais une
opportunisme en fait est-ce que vous
dites je crois qu'il y a un gain commun
de la de la Chine et des États-Unis sont
gagnants de la guerre d'Ukraine tous les
deux les États-Unis vont recommencer à
vassaliser l'Europe sur le plan
économique stratégique et militaire en
nous vendant du gaz de schiste dont nous
ne voulions pas encore il y a peu de
temps ce qui m'a opposé d'énormes
problèmes d'ailleurs sur le plan
de notre politique énergétique et
climatique et la Chine domine la Russie
même si elle n'a pas directement
apporter son alliance ça marche pas
comme ça nous projetons un peu nos
catégories nous demandons pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils ne font pas comme nous
mais c'est qu'ils sont différents ils
ont un mode de culture qui différents en
fait il est clair que dans que dans
cette affaire la Russie est maintenant
largement subordonnée à la Chine donc la
Chine aux États-Unis sont les deux
gagnants alors de quoi vont-ils parler
ben pour l'instant de pas grand chose
Pierre Antoine Denet vous êtes d'accord
il y a tout de même aussi cette
compétition d'un point de vue
technologique je sais que vous
connaissez bien ce sujet et c'est
intéressant d'en parler puisque les
États-Unis ont pris vraiment des mesures
très fortes pour empêcher les
exportations de ce qu'on appelle les
semi-conducteurs à la Chine et c'est
assez récent et ça fait vraiment partie
d'une nouvelle politique de Joe Biden
chacun veut gagner la compétition la
Chine et les États-Unis donc on se
demande quel peut être la valeur
effectivement de ces trois heures
d'entretien alors que d'un point de vue
technologique la guerre est totale ou
pas
je voudrais juste avant de vous répondre
plus directement reprendre ce que vous
venez de dire en ce qui concerne les
États-Unis et la géométrie variable de
des valeurs universelles ou de ce qu'on
appelle les droits humains
moi je dirais simplement que ça on
l'aide américaine à l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui l'Ukraine serait russe et là
franchement il y a peu de doutes
là-dessus alors c'est vrai que dans une
certaine mesure les États-Unis en
profitent l'industrie de l'armement
ronflent un régime c'est vrai et en même
temps je pense qu'il faut quand même
garder ça à l'esprit alors maintenant
s'agissant de cette concurrence entre la
Chine et les États-Unis sur le plan des
technologies effectivement c'est tout à
fait crucial parce que tout le monde
sait aujourd'hui que les les
semi-conducteurs c'est le nerf de la
guerre de cette nouvelle révolution
industrielle qui a commencé elle va tout
diriger elle dirige déjà beaucoup et ça
va continuer en s'affirmant encore plus
donc la suprématie mondiale que à mon
avis cherche aussi bien les États-Unis
que la Chine elle passe par là et là
c'est vrai que le travail des États-Unis
dans ce domaine est constant depuis un
certain nombre d'années mais il est en
train de s'accélérer je voudrais juste
revenir un instant sur le plan
géopolitique
pour poursuivre dans ce que je disais
tout à l'heure la Chine aujourd'hui est
quand même relativement en position de
faiblesse parce que aux États-Unis
face aux États-Unis mais pas seulement
là-bas on voit Joe Biden assister
maintenant à tous les grands forums
c'est un peu moins le cas mais vous
savez
cet esprit de conquête chinois qui est
apparu surtout avec seasing il indispose
comme un certain nombre de pays de la
région en Asie a commencé par le Japon
et la Corée du Sud mais pas seulement on
peut citer l'Australie et même au sein
de l'azéanne qui vient de tenir son
sommet beaucoup de pays se méfient
aujourd'hui de la Chine quels sont leur
alternatives j'en faisais des milliers
aussi se méfie de la Chine justement
le président
sating a dit le monde a besoin de la
Chine et la Chine a besoin du monde à
l'heure l'alternative et d'ailleurs
c'est peut-être ce qu'on est en train de
voir dans ce que j'ai appelé une pause
et ben c'est la respiration et la
nécessité de lâcher un peu la pression
et de laisser entrer bien sûr des
investissements il y a un enjeu énorme
en ce moment
sur la scène biologie on le disait aussi
donc celui-ci il y en a un autre la
Chine a aspiré énormément
d'investissements industriels venant de
l'étranger pendant des années ça
contribue de façon colossale à la
croissance de la Chine et là-dessus on a
enchaîné bien sûr sur l'OMC aujourd'hui
ce que fait miroiter le Chine c'est
partenaires c'est le marché financier ce
marché formidable des épargnants chinois
cette masse extraordinaire de l'épargne
chinoise pour l'instant il est très
interne ce marché justement regardez
tous les signes qui sont donnés regardez
les signatures de partenariat avec des
étrangers c'est probablement la nouvelle
étape de coopération souhaitée je ne
sais pas si elle va réussir mais ça
voudrait dire ouverture de la part de la
Chine et voilà et donc là c'est la
contradiction entre les flux
crématériels qui étaient des
investissements qui conduisaient à dû à
du hard du solide des des
usines avec quelque chose qui va être
beaucoup plus fluide qui va moins se
voir qui va circuler en principe plus
facilement si du moins les marchés de
capitaux chinois s'ouvrent qui seraient
l'afflux de capitaux étrangers purement
dans le domaine financier c'est un enjeu
qui est en train d'arriver donc en jeu
technologique en jeu financier et puis
bien sûr Taïwan c'est de la ligne rouge
elle dit si Jinping enfin en tout cas
les Chinois disent ceux-là Joe Biden lui
avait affirmé sur CBS qui
l'interviendrait en cas d'attaque de
Taïwan par la Chine on va l'écouter
absolument et Joe barian ne cesse de
faire un pas en avant un peu en arrière
parce qu'il est poussé par ses
conseillers c'est conseillers qui lui
rappellent il vient de le rappeler à
Bali que la politique de la Chine unique
à laquelle les États-Unis se sont tenus
pendant toutes les années 70 et 80 est
valait toujours et il
réinstore une forme d'ambiguïté
stratégique par rapport à Taïwan alors
qu'il a dit au moins quatre fois cinq
fois depuis qu'il est président des
États-Unis que oui il enverrait
effectivement les militaires américains
si Taïwan était envahi donc
effectivement à force d'ambiguïté dans
son propre discours on ne sait plus
quelle est la politique des États-Unis
mais à chaque fois on a vu les
conseillers de la maison blanche revenir
pour dire non non nous reconnaissons
toujours la politique de la Chine unique
c'est toujours la politique des
États-Unis on souffle le show et le
froid mais après tout est-ce si
important on voit comment les États-Unis
sont
omniprésents en Ukraine sans y être
comment ils ont fait basculer la gueule
la position de Taïwan en fait ce calcul
reste sur celle de l'aide américaine à
l'Ukraine c'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'ils disent pas exactement pareil non
mais chinoise n'est pas l'armée russe et
dans le même temps je ne dis pas que les
Chinois n'ont pas décidé tout seul de
lancer effectivement une offensive
financière mais je pense que les chinois
sont aussi en train de prendre des notes
par rapport au blocage financier qui qui
enveloppe la Russie aujourd'hui
retirer toutes les moyens de financement
étrangers via le dollar à la Russie à
isoler la Russie d'une manière sur un
plan économique d'une manière drastique
et les Chinois ont les moyen que la
Russie n'a pas de lancer effectivement
une dédolarisation globale qu'ils
avaient sans doute déjà un petit peu
amorcé je suppose avant Marie-Françoise
vous réagissez à cela est-ce que
effectivement il y a les leçons est-ce
que les chinois pensent à ce qui se
passe en Ukraine et à la manière dont
les États-Unis interviennent sans
intervenir alors lorsqu'il pense à
Taïwan nous avons tendance à projeter
sur la Chine qui est quand même un
univers culturel totalement différent
d'une autre dans ses valeurs depuis des
religions différentes des philosophies
différentes des modes d'action et de
vision du monde différent nous projetons
un petit peu trop je crois notre logique
du coup nous ne comprenons peut-être pas
certaines choses dans cette affaire de
Taïwan par contre là on est dans du
classique on a un pays qui défend ce qui
estime être son territoire et d'autres
pays qui disent finalement vous n'avez
peut-être pas le droit d'envahir quand
même un territoire dont on la retraite
reconnu sans que soit vraiment traité
international qui faisait partie de
votre de votre nation mais on est sûr de
rien là-dedans donc on projette et
finalement la Chine moi je suis frappée
par les analyses il y a eu beaucoup
d'analyses britanniques notamment
autrefois comme Joseph niedham qui
expliquait très bien que la Chine a une
vision du monde qui est une vision
horizontale et pas verticale comme la
nôtre en d'autres termes elle se situe
pas surnax sur une pyramide encore moins
sur l'axe du mal qui fut cher l'époque
on est au conservateur américain elle
situe plutôt dans la multipolarité et
ceci vous se voit très bien à travers
l'offensive qu'elle a fait avec l'OMC
les les routes de la soie qui sont une
énorme politique une politique
considérable qui la met en négociation
permanente en ce moment derrière avec de
nombreux pays l'Union européenne qui
commence il faut bien le dire à réagir
j'espère qu'on parlera de l'Europe dans
un instant et et la Chine va se faisant
en se faisant des amis ici ou là on voit
très bien le jeu qu'elle mène avec l'un
des réciproquements à tel point qu'on a
pu parler de multi alignements pour
certains pays comme l'Inde qui est un
concept quand même nouveau et manque pas
d'une forme je dirais d'humour si la
matière n'était pas aussi sérieuse
ne pense pas comme nous exactement
et donc la Chine avance d'une manière
beaucoup plus un peu plus comme la nappe
d'eau si vous voulez nous sommes dans la
pyramide alors tout ça ne marche pas
ensemble nous ne nous comprenons pas je
crois mais d'un point de vue compétitif
ou compétition économique par exemple je
pense que leur vision est peut-être plus
proche de celle des Américains
Pierre-Antoine Denet où est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
mais dans un instant mais juste pour
reprendre ce que vous dites c'est vrai
que la Chine Django c'est le pays du
milieu donc en fait il y a le centre du
monde et il y a les pays vassaux autour
et très franchement
dans une certaine mesure et si limping
suit cette politique
moi j'ai beaucoup lu sur justement ces
stratégies beaucoup plus enfantives de
site Jinping qui serait celle des loups
mais c'est ça c'est d'ailleurs
effectivement c'est une Chine
conquérante maintenant c'est une pin's
puisque la Chine bien sûr mais la Chine
à l'époque vous connaissez très peu le
monde extérieur comme nous-même nous
connaissions très peu ce qui était la
Chine mais alors sur l'aspect économique
et financier vous savez pendant des
décennies mon avis et qu'on a surestimé
la puissance de la Chine on a estimé que
la Chine était un eldorado pour les
investisseurs pour y faire des affaires
aujourd'hui il y a une très grande
déconvenue alors on parlait de l'aspect
financier vous avez monsieur di Magog en
partie raison bien sûr mais il faut
quand même savoir que le dollar c'est
plus de 85% des échanges mondiaux en
même temps là on passe de devenir la
première puissance économique mondiale
la Chine
justement
on verra on verra m’exprimer à l'instant
aujourd'hui pourquoi
le taux de croissance vous l'avez dit
du PIB chinois est en train de
dégringoler à tout à l'heure il sera
peut-être même largement inférieur à 3%,
ça ne s'est jamais vu depuis plusieurs
décennies
d'autre part
le chômage vous l'avez dit le chômage
des jeunes est supérieur à 20%. il y a
une certaine forme de désespérance mais
vous savez pour les investisseurs
étrangers ils commencent à réfléchir
avec en plus cette gestion d'appendémie
qui a été absolument épouvantable pour
l'économie chinoise donc on va on va en
parler mais tout de même Jean-François
du milieu pour rebondir il y a cette
vision de ces Jinping n'est-ce pas de
dire que c'est l'Occident qui est en
déclin et pas la Chine oui mais ça c'est
son travail écoutez je crois que nous
nous ne faisons pas assez notre travail
c'est à dire celui de dire que
effectivement
nous sommes peut-être traversés de
doutes mais ça c'est ce qui est
caractérise Occident je dirais presque
que c'est sa force parce que il n'est
pas monolithique comme les pays
autocratiques et donc étant capable de
nous remettre en doute nous identifions
aussi nos faiblesses et c'est plus les
faiblesses de la Chine c'est
probablement d'être tellement
affirmative et bien sûr quand on vous
avez un autocrate au pouvoir vous avez
beaucoup de mal à identifier vos et ça
je pense que c'est lubrif l'excès qui
menace aujourd'hui la Chine de Sitting
et donc probablement l'entourage de
sitting ou peut-être même lui-même on
peut rêver sans compte et cette pause
dont on parle tout à fait au début et
peut-être la conséquence des limites que
cette humoriste peut avoir alors ça ne
veut pas dire que ça va durer des années
ça veut juste dire qu'on a besoin de
respirer à mon cou c'est tout
à fait je la Chine pin c'est peut-être
pas tout à fait la Chine qu'on a connu
jusque là parce qu'il y a quand même
bien sûr c'était pas un régime autre
cotocratique c'est bien clair mais avec
sixième pin les boulons sont quand même
sérieusement resserrés et on a plus
beaucoup d'informations sur tout ce qui
pourrait être discussion au sein du
parti communiste ou des organes internes
on a l'impression d'une gélification et
ça c'est c'est certainement très mauvais
pour le pays je rappelle que lorsque les
États-Unis se sont comportés comme ce
que Hubert Védrines a très bien appelé
l'hyperpuissance
le risque de chute n'était pas loin
nous sommes arrivés nous sommes arrivés
à un degré où les États-Unis ont voulu
embarquer le reste du monde dans la
croisade contre le mal on se rappelle la
guerre d'Irak et en réalité aujourd'hui
il ne pourrait pas faire une chose
pareille donc ça donne la mesure quand
même de la façon dont le temps au passé
alors est-ce que la Chine n'est pas
aujourd'hui victime comme vous le dites
hybride est-ce que mais je ne crois pas
quand même je reviens sur ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure que la Chine vise le
statut d'hyperpuissance je crois qu'elle
veut être plutôt une puissance qui
contrôle dans l'horizontale tous les
différents molles ou pôles qui sont
aujourd'hui que qu'on trouve dans
l'ordre mondial les dirigeants européens
en tout cas ce sont accordés pour éviter
je cite une logique de confrontation
systématique avec Pékin et pour
développer leur propre modèle face à la
Chine en se démarquant aussi de
Washington on va écouter
ursulafanderlione la présidente de la
commission
ce que l'on voit c'est que la Chine est
de plus en plus affirmée nous avons des
champs de coopération surtout dans le
combat contre le changement climatique
nous cherchons des solutions communes
mais nous voyons aussi que la
compétition devient de plus en plus
difficile
elle parle de compétition aussi à donc
les Européens sont dans la compétition
avec la Chine et la Chine continue à
dire d'abord que l'Europe et son premier
partenaire commercial et que finalement
il y a de la place pour tout le monde ça
se cite le communiqué de Pékin
aujourd'hui il y a de la place pour tout
le monde dans cette compétition mondiale
y compris les États-Unis mais aussi
l'Europe c'est cette posture
multipolaire dont madame parlait c'est
effectivement aussi une Europe qui
continue à chercher une troisième voie
une forme de désescalade dans cette
logique de blocs qui est en train de
s'affirmer qui s'est beaucoup affirmé à
Washington ces derniers mois et qui
s'affirme de moins en moins parce que
les pays du Sud disent non donc à part
et parce que l'Europe également dit non
certes l'Europe aujourd'hui centre du
monde du fait de la guerre en Ukraine
est en mesure aussi de rappeler aux
États-Unis que son équilibre économique
n'est équilibre économique de l'Union
européenne
que les États-Unis et nous sommes
interdépendants et que donc on ne peut
pas se découpler comme les États-Unis le
dirait se découplage avec la Chine
brutale exigée technologiquement mais
également économiquement du jour au
lendemain on se souvient de la pression
faite sur Boris Johnson à l'époque au
Royaume-Uni pour surtout ne pas confier
la 5G à Huawei cette course à la
technologie qui est sans doute le
premier
l'absolu priorité à Washington
aujourd'hui développer la 6G avant la
Chine développer une cybersécurité qui
soit qui met les Etats-Unis à l'abri de
la Chine ceci rentre en résonance et en
même temps en concurrence avec
l'autonomie stratégique de l'Europe avec
notre propre préoccupation sur notre
cybersé etc et donc nous sommes
contraints à une troisième voie à un
finalement
non alignements n'ont pas un pluri
alignement mais un non alignement d'un
côté comme de l'autre parce que nous
nous retrouvons en concurrence et avec
la Chine bien évidemment dans cette
logique de bloc mais aussi avec les
États-Unis Marie-Françoise j'imagine que
vous êtes assez d'accord
justement si jinking à Pékin le 4
novembre dernier donc c'est intéressant
de parler le troisième voie européenne
alors que même alors que là on parle
plutôt de l'Allemagne commerciaux
à peu près directement auprès de la
Chine comme un grand comme seul un grand
peut le faire et quelques temps avant il
avait fait après un discours complet sur
l'avenir de l'Union européenne où il
enterrait le concept d'autonomie
stratégique en disant qu'il n'y aurait
de défense que par le dopage de
l'industrie allemande et son achat
d'appareil notamment aérien américain et
il a enté l'autonomie stratégique alors
il reste il reste pour l'Europe l'idée
de l'idée politique l'idée de l'union
politique est faite pour qu'il n'y ait
pas une élargissement trop rapide et mal
maîtrisée bien entendu mais l'idée du
lion politique elle-même devient très
fragile et je crois qu'elle je crois
qu'elle a pris un coup dans l'aile avec
le avec les récents en développement
avec la guerre à l'Ukraine et et même
avec leur rapprochement et même avec le
dialogue
sino-américain ou Pierre Antoine Denet
parce que c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
pour l'Europe elle est aussi compétitive
d'un point sur le micro justement les
microprocesseurs parce que l'Europe
aussi essaye de créer sa force même si
elle est en retard évidemment face aux
Etats-Unis et à la Chine et en même
temps en étant toujours le premier
partenaire commercial de la Chine est-ce
que c'est pas en même temps sont son
talon d'Achille enfin c'est pas facile
pour elle de s'affirmer face à la Chine
et en même temps la Chine ne peut pas se
défaire totalement de l'Europe alors on
est avec vous ça c'est vrai mais il faut
savoir que l'Union européenne pour la
Chine
était aussi inping un moyen de
contrebalancer les rapports exécrament
que la Chine avec les États-Unis
maintenant au-delà lors de ce voyage de
Monsieur schols à Pékin il y a eu
beaucoup de critiques au sein de l'Union
européenne y compris à la Commission
européenne certains ont dit y compris
dans son gouvernement d'ailleurs
sa ministre des Affaires étrangères a
clairement dit avant son voyage que le
danger ce serait de retomber dans
l'ornière de la dépendance que
l'Allemagne et l'Europe a connu avec la
Russie et que donc il faut en finir avec
cette naïveté une fois pour tous pour
toutes alors pour aller plus loin
c'était quand même un peu de germanifère
ce si je suis
vous savez
la principale puissance économique de
l'Union européenne c'est l'Allemagne
elle fait plus de la moitié de son
commerce extérieur avec avec la Chine
c'est parti quand même pour durer un
certain temps évidemment et là ces
intérêts à sauvegarder ça on peut le
comprendre alors pour la suite bah
écoutez oui il est allé là-bas je pense
qu'il a eu en tout cas au moins un
résultat souligner c'est
qu'effectivement ça a été la première
fois aussi divine a dit que le chantage
nucléaire russe était à condamné il n'a
pas dit lui-même parce qu'il ne peut pas
vis-à-vis de l'opinion publique chinoise
évidemment ça n'apparaîtrait pas dans
les journaux mais il ne peut pas le dire
comment dirais-je citer par l'agence une
nouvelle mais il a dit rapporté par
Monsieur Scholtz donc ça favorisé ce
type de d'affirmation côté chinoise de
ce dialogue voilà Emmanuel Macron
rencontre 6 inking de persuader de faire
pression sur la Russie pour que il
arrête ce conflit la personnellement
j'ai quelques doutes mais bon on verra
ensuite il est prévu aussi que Monsieur
Macron aille en Chine en visite
officielle au mois de janvier
je souscris je pense qu'effectivement il
ne faut jamais rompre le dialogue preuve
en est d'ailleurs que aujourd'hui le
dialogue renaît entre la Chine et les
États-Unis jean-François a dit médié oui
alors donc on revient à cette idée de
dialogue du début du sujet et ça
important ce dialogue de le maintenir
donc y compris quand on s'appelle Olaf
chaude y compris bien sûr quand on
s'appelle Emmanuel Macron qui va
effectivement voir ses Jinping cette
nuit avec le décalage horaire ça sera
cette nuit en France qu'est-ce qu'on il
a dit le président français qu'il allait
insister sur le fait qu'il est aussi
dans l'intérêt de la Chine de faire
pression sur la Russie il peut il peut
réussir encore une fois on ne peut pas
dans le rôle où on est quand on est
président français dire ce qu'est
l'intérêt de la Chine de la même façon
que quand on est baiden on ne peut pas
dire ce que l'intérêt de la Chine c'est
la Chine qu'il décide on peut avoir une
opinion sur ce qui est l'intérêt de la
Chine mais on ne peut pas savoir ce qui
dans la tête d'un dirigeant chinois et
l'intérêt de la Chine c'est son travail
à lui donc la bonne nouvelle et c'est
effectivement que Emmanuel Macron par la
par la sitting c'est évident il faut
maintenir le dialogue l'extrême bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'effectivement ça se
passe en terrain neutre si j'ose dire
dans le cadre d'un G20 qui consacre le
multilatéralisme et non pas dans le
cadre d'une visite bilatérale la petite
mauvaise nouvelle c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça parce que ça c'est la
résonance est différente parce que on a
failli vous permettez avoir un voyage
présidentiel qui aurait eu lieu dans la
foulée par exemple du voyage au G20
la très bonne nouvelle ça aurait été un
voyage commun de la Scholtz et
d'Emmanuel Macron qui aurait été
symétrique de la rencontre des
dirigeants européens avec sitting en
2010 en 2019 ça ne s'est pas produit
donc la France est tout à fait dans son
rôle en face je dirais d'une Allemagne
comme on l'a dit qu'il pense à ses
intérêts mais qui est dans une position
totalement asymétrique parce qu'elle est
beaucoup plus dans le court terme parce
que l'Allemagne doit défendre
impérativement ces statues sont
commerces extérieures et puis surtout
j'irai de couvrir le risque que son
vieillissement très rapide lui fait
courir alors que effectivement
finalement le déficit français vis-à-vis
de la Chine il y a toujours existé on
aura beaucoup de mal à l'inverser en
revanche le creusement du déficit
allemand en face de la montée en
puissance des voitures électriques
chinoises que vous commencez à voir dans
les rues de Paris ça c'est quelque chose
qui menace beaucoup plus directement
l'Allemagne que ça ne menace la France
qu'est-ce qu'on peut attendre justement
de cette rencontre entre le site Jinping
et Emmanuel Macron je crois que la
différence première entre Emmanuel
Macron et Olaf Scholtz c'est qu'il
représente c'est qu'Emmanuel Macron
représente une puissance nucléaire et
que suite aux appels téléphoniques entre
l'oeil d'Austin le ministre de la
Défense américain avec son homologue
russe et depuis comme par hasard les
Russes ne parlent beaucoup moins voire
ne parle plus d'utiliser des armements
nucléaires tactiques en Ukraine le
nucléaire est revenu au centre de la
table via la Corée du Nord
qui a suspendu ses tirs domicile pendant
le G20 de l'Indonésie peut-être pendant
quelques jours on va avoir un petit peu
de détente de ce côté là aussi mais
aussi par rapport à l'accord nucléaire
iranien et au à l'hypothétique retour
des États-Unis cet accord qui a été dont
les négociations ont été suspendues le
temps d'avoir le retour électoral des
États-Unis mais qui pourrait reprendre
alors c'est le énième épisode on le sait
mais la question nucléaire depuis que de
toute façon la Russie par son agression
de l'Ukraine c'est retiré de l'accord de
réduction des armes stratégiques qui
avaient pourtant été prorogées il y a un
an et demi maintenant entre Vladimir
Poutine et le jobiden Joe Biden vient de
nous le dire là il parle au chef d'État
il parle au chef d'État qui se comporte
comme tel qui sont raisonnables nous
dit-il c'est à dire ceux qui ont compris
que le sort de la planète se joue
peut-être en Ukraine et qui sont prêts à
dialoguer aussi sur la puissance
nucléaire c'est le rêve secret des
Américains jusqu'à présent la Chine a
dit non
soutenaient les efforts envers l'Iran et
servaient de médiateur sur la Corée du
Nord donc je ne doute pas que c'est l'un
des sujets effectivement qui se
discutent actuellement entre tous ces
grands dirigeants entre Emmanuel Macron
aussi et c'est jingle vous pensez cette
nuit peut-être dans notre beta il y a
vraiment la question européenne parce
que l'Europe je le disais est à mon avis
il a perdant dans la guerre du crâne
elle est perdante par la main mise que
des États-Unis notamment stratégiques
sur le continent européen et
naturellement par le fait que la Chine
monte très fort par rapport à une Russie
qui dans l'histoire il faudra bien que
la Russie se reconstruise en jour avec
un régime convenable si possible il
faudra bien que nous puissions continuer
autant que possible à parler à la Russie
qui appartient à notre continent donc là
dedans l'Europe si on regarde les choses
à nabîme le rose l'Europe est dans une
mauvaise situation me semble-t-il et la
France disant un petit mot de la France
quand même la France est très isolée en
Europe quand même parce que qu'il
s'agisse de s'entendre sur la question
énergétique et notamment du marché de
l'énergie et de l'approvisionnement
énergétique avec l'Allemagne
qu'il s'agisse de la souveraineté
stratégique c'est non encore une fois
dans ce discours de Prague Scholl ça
vient dit très clairement sans même
prendre la peine de dire non à la France
il a dit tout notre armement stratégique
sera désormais américain il y a aussi
naturellement l'avancée de l'OTAN qui ne
nous favorise pas et nous risquons quand
même l'isolement c'est pourquoi tout
tentative pour continuer à parler
notamment à la Russie tentative
valeureuse conduite par le président de
la République et je crois à soutenir
mais sans avoir trop d'illusions sur
notre futur immédiat
de cette émission est-ce qu'on est dans
un dialogue de sourd puisqu'on arrive un
peu à la conclusion de ce débat entre
sea Jinping et
Joe Biden moi je pense que non preuve en
est aussi que la prochaine étape sera la
visite du secrétaire d'État américain
blinken apk en principe au mois de
janvier et ça c'est un signe parce qu'en
fait il n'a jamais été en Chine depuis
qu'il est secrétaire d'État donc il y a
une volonté de part et d'autre de
poursuivre le dialogue pour moi c'est un
signe très sportifs on ne sait pas dans
quelle direction ça et ça ira mais je
prends en tout cas comme fête à qui que
la Chine aujourd'hui elle-même est assez
isolée et qu'elle a besoin de reprendre
ce dialogue pour sortir de cette
isolement
les dossiers les pires sont ceux qui ne
veulent pas entendre il y en a un des
deux qui a clairement entendu des
messages
contrairement à ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer la sortie du 20e congrès je
pense que c'est sitting effectivement il
a entendu le message qui vient de chez
lui c'est à dire très fort
ralentissement et puis comme vous le
disiez message de des pays des pays qui
l'entourent avec une remise en cause
très très forte du rôle de la Chine et
puis aussi un message des électeurs
américains on en a parlé le message des
électeurs américains il renforce Joe
Biden le rêve de Sitting ça aurait été
de voir un Joe Biden qui avait perdu
toute majorité dans son régime
démocratique ça renforçait à la fois la
version pour les régimes démocratiques
et
la volonté de parler à quelqu'un qui
était affaibli et bah non ça a pas
marché comme ça je sais pas si j'ai une
pin avait un tel intérêt à avoir venir
Trump ce profiler avec son agressivité
commerciale j'en dis pas tout à fait sûr
mais ce que je crois c'est
qu'effectivement le défi pour la Chine
et maintenant le défi économiquement
n'a pas tout à fait servi les intérêts
communs
l'excédent commercial chinois vis-à-vis
de des États-Unis n'a jamais été aussi
fort qu'après les mesures de Trump
donc il est plus protectionniste
absolument anxisèle donc un mode
conclusion sur dialogue de sourd ou pas
parce que là on parlait de la Chine qui
a entendu ce que disait Jean-François
dix millions est-ce que les États-Unis
entendu est-ce que Joe Biden a étendu
les Américains les Chinois le dialogue
est toujours une excellente nouvelle
maintenant le résultat des élections
législatives aux États-Unis le Sénat
certes les démocrates vont le contrôler
mais de justesse à nouveau et même si la
Chambre des Représentants le fossé entre
démocrates et républicain est en train
de se combler vraisemblablement les
républicains vont avoir une majorité le
mot clé chez Joe Biden depuis qu'il est
élu président c'est qu'il veut
réconcilier l'Amérique il veut une
politique bipartite et la Chine
la l'endiguement d'une Chine
révisionniste au perçue comme tel en
tout cas à Washington au niveau de
l'ordre mondial et le sujet par
excellence qui réunira républicain et
démocrate autour de la table donc je
doute fort que Joe Biden avait baisse sa
garde je doute fort historiquement Harry
Truman président démocrate dans les
années 50 quand en 1949 maoot c'est tout
gagne la Révolution les démocrates ont
perdu la à l'époque et ça aux États-Unis
tout le monde s'en souvient le Parti
démocrate auto de Joe Biden ne laissera
pas la Chine faire ce qu'elle souhaite
et elle ne pourra pas parce qu'elle a
besoin de cette alliance avec les
républicains en interne pour que
l'intégralité des avancées sociales ne
soient pas détricotées dans les 50 états
dans les années qui viennent donc ça
veut dire que manque de clarté enfin il
va y avoir
Washington ça veut dire que la ligne
dure va continuer à Washington parce
qu'elle est bi-partite et parce qu'elle
est vraiment le seul dossier sur lequel
les républicains et les démocrates
toutes elles confondues s'entendre vous
êtes d'accord
de ce point de vue là oui sur la ligne
mais la Chine l'enjeu des élections
américaines il sera l'enjeu des
élections américaines absolument mais
tout reste à savoir sur quoi la ligne
dure s'appliquera est-ce qu'elle servait
à un problème politique les moyens
d'action Taïwan ou est-ce qu'elle
préférait d'abord un problème économique
et puis il y a la cour iranien ou là
aussi on entendra les deux voies
dissonantes merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec ton mari
merci Marie-Françoise bestel merci
beaucoup Annick cisel merci
Jean-François dimiglio et Merci à VOUS
Pierre-Antoine Donnay merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivi vous restez avec
nous sur France 24